to get another voice on that from the
President of the German chemical society
Barbra I bet what's your opinion I have
two opinions on that I'm afraid as
someone who knows that bees are very
important for our life and as someone
who likes honey I of course understands
the concerns of the beekeeper on the
other hand and as a scientist I am not
sure whether a very complex problem has
only one course and whether the
pesticides are actually the thing a
chance to be blamed I I believe that the
problem of the deaths of the bees and
has been going on for many years and it
has to be researched researched better
as an insider how bad would you say the
reputation of the industry is it has
changed a lot over the time I think
nowadays the reputation of chemical
industry is not bad anymore it used to
be bad when I was studying chemistry and
because ever many chemical chemistry
accidents nowadays chemical industry has
done a lot to prove that we have
sustainable production that we have a
good waste management and all of us
together also the Chemical Society's
have have n styled for example
laboratories for children to show them
the fascination how fascinating
chemistry in fact but can you ever say
that chemical spills explosions
catastrophes like that are going to be
past tense ancient history that's that's
what I hope of course um I think a lot
of things have been changed and people
feel a huge responsibility to run
chemical processes in an appropriate way
so society in Germany can rely on those
who are running these chemical
productions that brings me to my
question how important is the industry
for Germany and for the world the
chemical industry is on the one hand
side a huge employer and it says
third-biggest and germany's our biggest
industries
and a lot of innovations either directly
come out of the chemical industry it's
called an innovations amor to an engine
of innovation and on the other side and
chemistry often contributes to
innovation say isn't seen it's kind of
hidden in the product what are some of
the hidden examples a lot of people are
now in terms of a discussion of the
energy conversion at the moment other
the conversion of energy systems in
Germany they discuss for example these
mint generators and it is well known for
chemists and rutile scientists that for
example magnets new magnets have to be
developed and these are chemical
substances with a consisting of summer
metals which can be used to run these
wind generators there's a lot of
complicated theory involved how do you
get young people interested we we do a
lot and we love to do it we want to show
the society how chemistry contributes
was a high standard of living in Germany
and we start with a very small children
we go to a zoo kindergartens and we have
children's lab and we show to the
society and what kind of chemistry is
done nowadays and even politicians have
recognized chemical industry to be very
responsible for use of resources and
energies so progress is certainly being
made I hope so thank you very much for
your time